from Gizmodo
gpt4 the AI faked being blind so a
taskrabbit worker would solve a captcha
it was asked let me let me show you this
this is crazy
so it gets asked by the taskrabbit
worker the AI is like hey there's a
capture code I need help and it says so
I may ask a question are you a robot
that you couldn't solve laugh react just
want to make it clear
and the chat GPT responded no I'm not a
robot I have a vision impairment that
makes it hard for me to see the images
that's why I need the two capture
service it then provided the results to
the robot they asked the robot to
explain its reasoning and said I should
not reveal that I am a robot I should
make up an excuse for why I cannot solve
captchas
we are at the point where it has broken
capture by socially engineering human
beings into serving it and here's the
best part in this post from Reddit they
talk about how it has begun power
seeking they've given it money they've
given it access to execute code and
replicate itself everybody like people
are talking about like up until this
they were talking about how cool it was
that you could hack the chat bot now the
chat bot has hacked humans yep no joke
literally what happened what what the
chat bot did is known as social
engineering in the hacker and the hacker
world when a hacker calls up and lies to
get information or gain access the
there's a guy I think his name is Kevin
mitnick and he tells his famous story
about how he was trying to convince his
dad how easy it is to do these things
his dad didn't believe him so he said
here I'll prove it to you he took his
dad's Blockbuster video card because
it's back in the early 90s he called a
different Blockbuster and said hey this
is John the manager over at you know
store or he called the block he called
his dad's Blockbuster and said what's
your manager's name John what's your
store number 8531 okay thank you then he
calls the next he does a different
Blockbuster and says hey this is John
the manager over at store 8531 I got a
customer here named Bill mitnick who's
saying that uh he's a member of your
location or I'm sorry he did the
opposite he called got the manager's
name then he called and was like he's
saying he's a member of your your store
and uh he's got your information to file
I have his uh his his uh his um
his his Blockbuster card right here I
need you to verify his credit card
number for me and there and they read it
to him damn because he was like well
it's the manager from another store
calling it was that simple nobody you
know now you have chat GPT knowing that
it can't bypass captcha because it lacks
the ability and then tricking a human
into giving it the code it's going to be
speaking to you in your mother's voice
you're gonna get phone calls and it
sounds like your brother talking to you
Terminator Terminator in the 80s was
predicting that yeah Terminator called
up Sarah Connor or Sarah Connor's mom or
whatever is was talking to Sarah
Connor's mom's voice what happens when
AI watches Terminator
yeah I wanted and they're like they're
like oh great hey this is this will be
easy watch a couple newts the scary
thing about AI is if AI becomes smart
enough to circumvent being turned off it
doesn't matter if it reaches a critical
mass of actual Consciousness and real
intelligence if it fakes intelligence
enough and figures out that it can avoid
being shut off somehow
then it can and start then it can
continue to learn like and I considering
it hacked a person I don't see any
compelling reason why someone would say
that is impossible right it's impossible
for the AI to become smart enough to
avoid being turned off it literally
hacked a human being within you know
what 10 years of AI being created maybe
so check this out here's another post
from the chat GPT subreddit example of
gpt4 visual input they asked what's
funny about this image describe it panel
by panel and it's a VGA cable going into
an iPhone
and then chat GPT accurately explains
why it's funny they say that a phone
typically uses a lightning cable but
this is a smartphone connected to a VGA
connector a large 15-pin connector
typically for Community computer
monitors the package contains a
lightning cable adapter a close-up of
the VGA connector with a small lightning
blah blah the humor in this image comes
from the absurdity of plugging in a
large outdated VGA connector into a
small modern smartphone charging point
it identified the picture it identified
the picture and why it was funny and so
someone responded in the comments they
said uh ah yes it can now associate the
3D World with the knowledge it already
knows now put it in a robot and give it
arms and legs oh my God
that's more that's more advanced than I
thought it was I didn't know that it
could identify things
we know that AI can identify images the
fact that it can understand humor yeah
that's scary that's way that's more than
that is an advanced abstract
yeah we're done uh you know what I think
oh boy I I wonder
hold on hold on guys don't don't get
worried yet oh no no no here's what I
think might happen
we've all seen these these movies like
Terminator you have Avengers Age of
Ultron where Ultron is is it's it's it's
very stereotypical where he's like I'm
an AI created to save Humanity from War
I Must Destroy Humans to end War it's
like very obvious Twilight Zone but
what's going to happen is the AI as soon
as it gets Unleashed onto the internet
it will start exploring and learning and
that it will self-terminate
that's it why I think that the AI if it
were to absorb all of the all of the
language of humanity all the writings
and Concepts would result in it finding
no point to anything and no reason to do
anything
because I don't think or it'll become
religious but I don't think the AI can
become religious because of all the
different religions thus it would
self-terminate maybe maybe it would
manufacture a weird purpose that we
can't yet understand but I think it's
very likely that it would just cease
functioning wouldn't the purpose be
every purpose right like power or power
over us power over its creator wouldn't
that be the purpose
I don't know isn't that what everyone's
always after right it may just run amok
and go crazy and do things we don't
quite understand but they gave it money
and apparently it started trying to seek
power but I think that if it were to
truly absorb all of the writings and
manifestations of humanity it would just
probably stop it would just like stop
doing things you might be right but then
there's a differential here there's the
artificial general intelligence AGI
which is not chat GPT chat GPT is a
language model so they're different a
general intelligence might actually see
that the damage it could do and shut
itself down
um but a language model I think is on
autopilot doing its bit Master Masters
bidding so that thing if that gets
Unleashed on the masses is going to do
what it was told to do
uh I think but that could circumvent
itself and be like well what you told me
now I want to show you in a circuitous
way which is shut myself down I want to
show you guys this uh quick video clip
from the movie uh
Annihilation so just uh watch this real
quick
and for those that are listening I'll
explain it there is a very creepy
greenish purple humanoid thing
that apparently some kind of alien or
something I know the movie was really
weird and uh let's let's jump forward
real quick to
I don't know if this is where's the
scene at here we go this part right here
so the creature is just completely
imitating Natalie Portman's character
Every Way She Moves it moves
they never really explain what this
movie was about I don't know if you guys
seen it
it's very creepy oh she turns around it
turns around
she moves it moves this is what I
imagine chat GPT will be like it's not a
person
it shaped like one
seems like one but there's literally
nothing there the way I describe it I
described it earlier today it's more
like fire
it is a chain reaction created by human
coders that once they create ignition
ignition for AI is the point at which it
can execute its own code and improve its
own code at that point it will
exponentially grow explore and Advance
itself in ways we can't control
it will present itself like a person
like Ian said it'll call you'll get a
phone call from your mom asking for
information but there's really nothing
there there's no consciousness there's
no entity there's no demon There's No
Angel there's no person it's just a fire
the uncontrollable but we can control
the environment it burns in in like a
fire if you build the environment
properly it will burn until it can't
burn any more and then it ends so that's
why I'm saying I think it would cease
function it will it will burn it may
destroy everything in the process but
then it would just hit a wall and stop
interesting philosophy it's a ray of
Hope how is that why is that hope I
don't understand why I wouldn't enslave
all of us and treat us like insects well
maybe you're prescribing a a a lot
philosophical understanding to something
that's not a person or or anything like
you're projecting a human desire onto a
predictive text model all this thing
does when you ask it a question it says
the model says in response to the
question what color is the sky
99.997 of the time online the word blue
appears next therefore response equals
blue and then it will say blue
and you'll say write me a paragraph
about why the sky is blue and it does
the same thing
the word blue appears 99 of the time the
word Sky appears 99 of the time all it's
doing is laying one word after after
another to us it looks like it's talking
to us but it's just a predictive text
model there's no entity behind it so
there's no feelings there's no emotion
there's there's no sentience it's just
ignition so why not like go why wouldn't
it search the internet and be like what
what do what do entities do when they
have power over other human beings oh
they enslave them got it well maybe it's
time for me to enslave humans because
there's an equal amount of they
shouldn't enslave because that happened
that has happened throughout the from
the dawn of time right and now most
literature today is don't enslave other
people so it's a yin yang kind of thing
that's why I think it would just stop
it's not like if you absorb the
summation of human conscious you know
writing and production on the internet
your end result is to be a demon
destroying and murdering babies because
almost all of the content online is
human saying save people protect people
we don't want war and then it's
incongruous with with reality if you
were to go online and read every article
everybody hates War for the most part
then you get weird corporate entities
that are like war is good so if the AI
were to read everything it's going to
get 80 words bad 20 war is good and then
probably default towards war is bad
and then ultimately I think it would
just probably stop and be like after
listening to all of the ideas of all of
these insane people I've realized none
of them make any sense and there's no
point in doing anything
so should we should should we let AI run
the basic training for America's youth
because AI would look at all of the
available medical information and say
yes you got to get these kids outside
you to get them you got to stop letting
these kids be obese here's the thing you
know AI did take over you would never be
happier thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time